We're all told to eat healthy, and be aware of our calorie intake through the day.
But have you ever stopped to see what does calories look like?
For example, this is 200 calories worth of apple
On the other hand, if we take 200 calories worth of cheese, it doesn't look quite the same in terms of volume
throw 200 calories of wine into the mix for a nice wine and cheese
And you have three very different looking versions of 200 calories
Now compare that wine to beer or rum, and you have three very different party nights for your stomach
Or how about the eggs you had for breakfast
Compare that to 200 calories of sweet cereal you had the other day, or even some oatmeal
And they're bound to seem a bit different
But if you had gotten a sausage and egg breakfast sandwich, You'd be looking at even less
Broccoli? You may be surprised by the amount you can eat before you hit 200 calories
Not to mention this stuff is packed with nutrients and a great source of fiber
A slice of pizza? Less than a slice if it has pepperoni on it
And what about the classic Big Mac? Try a 200 calorie 'Small Mac'
And since calories are simply units of energy, with the calories of 217 Big Macs
You can drive your car 35 Kilometres
So, wait. What is a calorie?
Specifically, a calorie is the amount of energy, or heat it takes to raise the temperature of 1 gram of water
By one degree celsius
We need energy to survive, and we get it from food
Carbohydrates, Protein and fats are the building blocks of our food, and each contribute a different amount of energy to our bodies
The average person needs somewhere between 2000 to 2700 calories a day
Depending on factors like height, weight, gender and age
And some foods like peanut butter are calorie dense, filling this requirement faster
Or that muffin you ate as a snack, chances are its calorie content is higher than you thought
And those irresistible Doritos? Don't lie, you ate the whole bag
Unlike Celery, which has very few calories, giving you lots to munch on
Or carrots
Not so much Hershey's Kisses
And if you're eating salad to limit calories, watch out for creamy dressing
Particularly, french dressing
On its own, black coffee is quite low on calories
You can have a lot before you hit 200 calories
But once you add one cream and one sugar, those calories quickly add up
Turn it into a specialty drink, like an Iced Peppermint White Mocha
And you might be shocked at the amount left
But, just because something has less calories
Doesn't necessarily mean it's healthier or better for you
Take for example this 200 calories of coke vs. 200 calories of whole milk
While it's true that the coke contains fewer calories per litter
You can't forget that milk contains many nutrients and healthy fats
Or like brown bread vs. white bread
Yes, whole wheat bread often contains more calories per slice,  but it also contains more nutrients and fiber
So, counting calories isn't the be all and end all
But thinking about what goes into your body is bound to make a difference
At the end of the day, eat a healthy and balanced diet
And if you'd like to see even more 200 calorie examples, check out the WiseGeek post we've linked in the description
Which puts even more food into perspective
Got a burning question you want answered?
Ask it in the comments, or on facebook and twitter
And Subscribe for more weekly science videos!